as he receives the award from red sox
manager alex cora please welcome the
2021 red sox roberto clemente award
nominee nathan ivaldi well here we go
chris sale on the bump it is a sale day
on this friday evening at fedway sale in
his first start since labor day mott
castle with the lefty on the mound
mullins has shown no signs of running
here 2-2
on the ground towards short bogarts
flips iglesias turns and there's two
behind chris sale
coming up in this nothing nothing game
2-2 to mancini is queued to short center
where the glaciers backpedaling and it's
three up three down thanks to the double
play for chris sale yeah kagan aiken
coming off his uh best start but the
last five of them have been good two
outlaws xander bogarts and now anken
will deal with rafael devers
to the slider there and devers drills it
toward left center and off the wall
bogarts will stop it third on a wall
ball double from devers
that's an outstanding job letting that
ball get deep akin had to come to him
right there with that ball just below
the belt right there you see him watch
it at the barrel driving it to left
field the red sox with two men in
scoring position in two outs one two on
the way
popped him up
severino gets rid of the mask
and makes the grab for the third out so
the red sox leave two in scoring
position to go to the second no score
orioles and red sox no score as we head
to the second inning for sale will face
austin hayes
there's his swing and a deep fly ball
out to left field climbing towards the
monster it hits off the light station
and he's gone
make it blackjack for austin hayes it's
21 home runs and tonight it's a
one-nothing lead for the orioles in the
second against sale and the red sox he
is having himself some type of a
september right now six home runs make
that seven he is heating up
in the biggest of ways so far we haven't
seen the swings and misses you normally
do against chris
whoa that was nasty on a slider that
went from the left-hand box to the
right-hand box and he strikes out urias
and the first k that pitch started in a
different area code that was behind him
by the time he cut to the glove
well trickler towards second iglesias
handles it to end the inning but the
orioles take the lead on an austin hayes
home run there's one man out at a hard
hit ball for christian vasquez
vasquez tugs this down the line that's a
fair ball and it'll roll into the corner
mckenna collects and christian vasquez
has a one-out double christian is it
second base bringing up alex verdugo 2-2
pitch
swinger shot up the middle will sneak
through diving stab bubble by the
shortstop he does keep it in front to
prevent a run from scoring so that would
be an infield hit for verdugo it seemed
to slow down around the mound and then
valencia doesn't have the greatest range
with diving behind second base even if
he comes up with it i don't think he
would have had verdugo jose with the red
sox is sitting 400 he's eight for 20
with a home run and four runs knocked in
oh two again
iglesias lines it down the right field
line that is fair and that is up over
the wall for a double this game is tied
from iglesias
outstanding at bat by iglesias right
there getting himself into a position
where he can had to come to him
something he can handle goes right with
it for a ground rule double second and
third for [ __ ] he was all for his last
12.
and he goes first pitch swinging and
skies this one to center
berdugo readies at third as mullins
approaches and the red sox take the lead
it's a sac fly from [ __ ] hernandez
outcastle retired six to three trey
mancini steps in 2-2 pitch by chris sale
ground ball denver's going to have to
hustle in place it bare-handed oh what a
nice play by rafael devers chris sale
gives him a nod as he gets the ball from
the umpire terrific play by devers
played it with a bare hand and gunned
the strong throw to dalbeck to get trey
mancini he's become so good at that
that's not an easy thing to do he does
have good sized hands sale facing austin
hayes who hit that big home run earlier
and this is line to center right at [ __ ]
hernandez and a one two three fourth on
nine pitches for sale
dalbeck lined out to the right fielder
austin hayes in his first at-bat two on
to dalbex
and he pulls this one toward the monster
and
that ball is gone dulbeck does it again
i mean he is seeing the ball i mean
everything he's hitting is an absolute
rod
we saw what he could do last season
eight home runs in the shortened season
this year he started off a little bit
slow but he has absolutely made that
adjustment here we go with chris sale to
face ramon yurios the second baseman the
rookie struck out his first time up
here's the one two and genius grabs it
weakly over the mound charged by bogarts
has to baryon throws on the move and got
him great play on both ends as dalbeck
scooped it out of the dirt zander
charging he had to make a bare hand play
do or die and he made it cleanly and
made a strong throw online dug up by
bobby the orioles have got their first
base runner since the second inning 2-2
pitch
swing of fly ball left field right there
verdugo about five feet in front of the
track makes the catch to retire the side
79 pitches for sale and after four and a
half three to one red sox renfro takes
third he's there with two down for jd he
fouled to the catcher and he hit a fly
ball to center 2-2
martinez goes the opposite way in the
right field down for a hit
it brings in renfro jd motors to second
with a one-scoring double that's what
i'm talking about right there being able
to see that pitch away that's a little
bit elevated on the outer half keeping
the hands back keeping a flat barrel
throughout the zone getting on top of it
letting it get deep outstanding job
right there by jd it all started with
vasquez he gets a single and then
verdugo just a sandwich into the
outfield but then hernandez getting a
wall hunter renfro steps in with the
bases loaded
2-2 pitch
and renfro laces it center field mullins
and it gets past him to the wall
vasquez scores fertugo's right behind
him [ __ ] on his heels and renfro clears
the bases into the gap mullins isn't
able to get to it clears the bases
outstanding outback by renfro right
there first out of the inning is
registered here and that will bring up
austin hayes as austin hayes lifts this
one into the corner
and fertugo makes the running catch wow
excellent job by ferdugo get into that
ball if you're going to get to that you
got to sprint from your first step matt
barnes pitching for the first time in
nearly three weeks with two on here in
the eighth the 2-2 to mount castle and
he got him swinging welcome back matt
barnes so with two down here he is
richie martin in the air to right and
renfro
and the red sox win the opener 7-1 the
final here at fenway taking down the
orioles